rien de chemin je vous pose pas une
colle parce que vous disiez on aimerait
bien savoir si un spin doctor ou qui
écrit c'est ses discours je sais pas si
quelqu'un autour de la table à la
réponse mais qu'est-ce qui vous fera de
vous dans le voilà la victoire du verre
dont on parlait gala il y a une petite
[Musique]
âne qui entourent ce ski et qu'il aide
ce qui est intéressant c'est que
beaucoup viennent sont des dialogues
sous des scénaristes beaucoup viennent
de sa maison de production notamment le
principal d'entre eux je crois que c'est
pas une yurioscout et tel qu'il me l'a
raconté en fait il réunit son équipe une
semaine avant un événement comme celui
qu'on a vu par exemple quand il va à
Londres et il leur donne quelques
éléments de de voilà le thème quelques
éléments mais alors peut-être qu'il m'a
dit je ne sais je ne dis pas ça pour
flatter le président mais c'est quand
même lui qui a toujours les bonnes idées
les meilleures c'est possible parce
qu'il en a beaucoup et voilà il
travaille donc en fait je je faisais le
parallèle en France sont plutôt des
normalisiens parfois des énarques plutôt
des normalisé qui travaillent et là
c'est d'abord une autre génération enfin
pas forcément une autre génération mais
c'est un autre profil qu'on a un peu
méprisé on se disant mais c'est très
difficile de faire une scénario un
scénario sites comme il faut être très
intelligent très vif et voilà c'est ils
viennent de au fond d'un circuit qu'on
ne connaît absolument pas en France
[Musique]